curious to know what lessons you guys
have learned about the software and the
hardware experience maybe you didn't see
coming until you at all it's time to do
more research you know one thing we
definitely have blonde on the genial
really focused on to improve for the new
prototype was the how to make it so easy
200 you know we are very proud when we
announced last year the early prototype
no first prototype you know how the
headset is designed so that the weight
of the unit is a you know supported on
the head not on the face yeah so we
heard it was very comfortable however
because it had like a tube and in a
plastic band and soft pan it a bit
complicated for people to handle by
themselves so we always needed someone
to support you know a person will try so
the Indian really worked hard to improve
it to make it very very simple to put it
on and take off so that one thing you
know be long it's only investing right
now and the experiences that will be
available with his launches there is a
mostly going to be tech demos and stuff
like that many studios overalls working
on actual games and that we haven't
talked about these games as yet and we
are waiting for the right time starting
probably at e3 we start to show the
actual games in addition to the perhaps
more developed demos that these teams in
from London was open studio have been
working on you know lots of people
consumers with annoying ask and a part
of that is because of the pasta
initiative that we have like a 3d stuff
topic gaming we you know current kind of
encourage that any game can be made into
3d Scott you know stereoscopic so there
again that also work on 3d TV but we are
is totally different you know because
you are not playing the game you know
outside of the gaming world you are
inside the gaming world the game has to
be photo/ed design in most cases and
people will start to see the difference
when they have a chance to try so in it
will take time but that's a little
important indication
you know you have to do what excites me
most is from our experiencing you know
experience launching many platforms it's
always you know someone who do not
expect you know come up with totally new
ideas and brought anybody's not mind is
there a price point that you guys would
like to hear what is the ideal yeah
retail price best well as low as it
possibly can be done yeah the goal is to
deliver experiences to people you know
that's what we want so the hardware
could be as low as we can deliver a good
experience that's what we want it to be
is it outside of the realm of two
hundred dollars with various passion we
are not talking about any specific
number but always this is a console
business you know we try to provide the
hardware at the lowest possible cost so
that people more people can come in and
so that people can you know make games
on to create the market so we have the
same of roads